hey david does it matter that most
trumpists still don't accept that donald
trump lost this is a really good
question
there's two answers does it matter
electorally no i mean
i know we hear about an audit looking
for bamboo fibers in arizona
and something's happening in michigan
and north carolina and you know whatever
going to have zero electoral impact
other than
continuing to push republicans to try to
suppress even more of the vote in 2022
and certainly in 2024
for me the fact that most republicans
still don't believe trump lost
is disturbing is because of what it
represents about the united states of
america
i don't believe that you can have
long-term
stability of institutions of government
of a society of a culture
when you don't even have agreement as to
what
are facts again i didn't say what the
facts are
there is not even agreement now as to
what constitutes a fact
a statement of fact an empirical
statement and as i've said before
we can disagree when it comes to our
opinions about things
but when one is presented with facts
about what took place
and you respond with my opinion is
different you were
outside of the world of empiricism you
were outside of the world of fact and
rationality and thinking
how does a country remain stable when
you have
so much of one party that believes the
person who won didn't really win
he won by millions of votes other than
some
typical anecdotal but statistically
insignificant irregularities
this was not a close election and then
on the basis of that
false belief they support a literal
insurrection
uh the vaccines work covet is real biden
one
these are facts and they don't believe
them they don't understand that they are
facts it is not subject to opinion
and so that the election is not accepted
as legitimate
is really a sign of a mass
radicalization
it's a mass delusion it's a tribal
psychosis
as i've referred to it before but they
believe that
even their ability to comment on this is
being silenced by their political
enemies as they see them when it's not
they're just wrong they just don't have
the facts on their hands and if they
start
winning elections through more voter
suppression which is what they plan to
do
and they ramp up this dehumanizing
rhetoric
against their political enemies history
points in bad directions when that
happens
so i worry we will see even more overt
political violence than we're already
seeing
we can look at all sorts of other
injured or imperfect democracies around
the world
and you start seeing really ugly things
happen in and around elections
and so i think that there is uh
it's easy to laugh off and say stupid
trump is who just can't accept the facts
yeah that's true but this is a much
bigger
issue and think back to when trump was
asked in 2016
if the results say you lost
will you accept that you lost and he
said i'm going to wait and see
i'll keep you in suspense that was a
dangerous vile statement
that didn't get nearly the blowback at
the time
everybody even republicans then should
have said that has to be rejected period
and republicans voted the guy in they
did the opposite which in essence
endorses that type of thinking that
leads and points towards tyranny
so on a day-to-day level listen i don't
want an accountant who thinks trump won
i don't want a doctor who thinks trump
won i don't work with
or hire people who have such delusional
beliefs that's something i do at a
personal level
uh but there is a bigger issue here and
the degree of radicalization and
separation from reality that it points
to
if we look historically it does not bode
well for the united states that's where
i would
i would leave it and i'm curious to hear
from you
make sure to get yourself a membership
on my website today
at joinpakman.com and thus
you will get instant access to today's
bonus show i'll see you then
one of our sponsors is vincero watches
giving you 15
off a high quality wristwatch is the
perfect way to
elevate your style own at least one
watch
that makes you feel great when you put
it on you can often see me wearing
my vincero watch on the show mine is the
gunmetal
vessel model i'm a big fan of the
metallic look
of the face of the watch i like the
silicone strap
you won't find a better made watch for
this good a price
anywhere else when you put it on you
know you got more than you paid for
vincero believes in crafting super
quality watches from high-end materials
but selling them at fair prices which is
why they have over twenty six thousand
five star reviews and they stand behind
every watch they make with a one-year
return policy
and five-year warranty they'll give you
fifteen percent off everything in their
store and free shipping
at davidpakman.com watch use the coupon
code
pacman